foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview it's the first look at what is
on the front pages as they arrive well
it's time to see what's making the
headlines that is with the columnist
Carol Malone and editor of The Courier
David clay good evening to both of you
Carol raspenden in pink there um they're
going to be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's take a look at
what is on some of those front pages
well the eye reports that there will be
no major tax cuts this year after the
bank of England's decision to raise its
base rate again
while the express focuses on the bank of
England Governors optimism for the UK
economy
but the financial times leads with the
efforts of tech talks chief executive to
avert a U.S ban of the viral video app
according to the guardian taxpayers have
spent close to half a billion pounds
buying beds in England's worst Care
Homes over the past four years
the front of the Metro is the story of a
wealthy Nigerian politician and his wife
who are facing jail in the UK over a
kidney swap plot
and the Daily Mail says there are
reports that some barristers are
refusing to prosecute climate activists
and
here's one have killer machines taken
over the world that is the question
that's being asked on the front of the
Daily Star well a reminder that by
scanning the QR code that you'll see on
the screen during the program you can
check out all of the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
talk about them well as I was saying
we're joined this evening by Carol
Malone and David Clegg a very warm
welcome to both of you two thank you for
joining us here on Sky News let's jump
straight in shall we um unsurprising on
a day that we get an NPC rates decision
um that we have the front of the eye in
a fairly oblique prognosis about
household finances Carol
yeah it is it's gonna be no tax cuts
because of this this interest rate rise
we kind of all knew was coming
um we hoped it wasn't we hoped it would
Peak the last time but now it's gone up
from four percent to four point two five
uh we're told that you know that this is
probably going to be the last that this
will be the peak but who knows um the
bank this is going to be this is a real
a real blow to households all over the
country just recently they got told
people got told that they were probably
going to save about 500 quid now on
energy builds in a year because the
price of that is coming down so but that
is now all going to be eaten up by this
rise you know so they're like 55 of
mortgages in the UK
um are on a fixed rate and the deal
expires this year so all of those people
are going to go from one point something
to four point whatever it is you know
variable rate so they're going to be hit
really hard we're told it's because of
the the rise in food prices which is
shocking at the moment it was to do with
the veg prices about three weeks ago but
you know Andrew Bailey the the bottom of
the bank of England says we're not to
worry he says because he's hopeful that
the economy is going to grow this year
and not be in the second quarter not
being the negative I was North Point or
negative but you know every time Andrew
Burnley says anything it goes
but this is a really big blow for people
at a time when they're they're food
prices you know I think there's a lot of
profiteering going on at the minute with
supermarkets and in garages and you know
they're using the cost of living crisis
to just jack up the prices little and
older you put up the prices by 25 in the
past few months and the rest of them
it's an average about 17 you need to
take the mortgage out now for a tub of
butter it's ridiculous so all of this is
going to hit people really hard yeah I
mean they're difficult headlines aren't
they David for a government that claims
it's got a grip on the cost of living
crisis
yes it is a difficult they are difficult
headlines tomorrow about this I think it
will cause great concern amongst the
public it is I think as Carol says
almost an unexpected blow I think the
the real problem was yesterday with the
user inflation had unexpectedly rose
again to 10.4 which is provoked this
decision which I think is the 11th
interest rate rise and we're not at a
level not seen since the immediate
aftermath of the financial crash in
2008. I think the other problem is that
the public are concerned about is that
when we have these interest rate Rises
we immediately see an impact on mortgage
mortgages we knew the chaos that has
been caused and the mortgage markets in
the last six months or so the the fact
that these have increased so much what
we don't see on the other end of course
is for Savers the advantage of of higher
interest rates the banks are a lot
slower to pass that on I I I was looking
yes yesterday actually and it was uh it
was hard to see much available over one
percent perceiving as far as I could see
unless you're dealing with a great deal
of money uh and and have the time to
invest it over the long term so I I
think what the public would like to see
really is action not just from the
government but from the banks as well
where they've they've had this there's
been this response uh as far as
mortgages is concerned there needs to be
an equivalent response in regards to the
type of interest you can get if you've
got some money and you're putting it in
an account to save it so I think that's
one thing there the other thing on the
government however though is I think
there is a little uh silver lining for
the government as well they do seem a
lot less convinced that the UK is going
to tip into a technical recession uh I I
think that was widely expected until
quite recently so the fact that they're
not saying they're a bit more optimistic
about that is perhaps one good sign for
Rishi sunak uh the other the other thing
that comes that comes out from the Ft
article in particular as you might
expect David the bank of England of
course looking at their twin remit of
not of not just prices but also
Financial stability saying that even
after all the turmoil we've had over the
last week or two uh the financial system
they say is safe
I I think that was it was a very
interesting decision they had to make
today because in the last 10 days or so
we've had two unexpected events really
which is the banking issue In America
which is then fed through the the Global
Financial system we saw the big problem
with credit so it's there's been a major
major concern about what exactly was
going on there and and what they have
decided today is that they believe their
private they are prioritizing concerns
over inflation rather than concerns over
Financial stability but that is probably
a welcome sign because we we know
exactly what the inflation problem is we
know exactly why it's there it's been
driven by uh Energy prices by Workforce
shortages
we were a little bit less I think
certain of exactly what was going on
with the banking system and exactly how
uh the events uh in Silicon Valley could
Ricochet through the system so the fact
that they've looked at this and taken
the view that uh the inflation there's a
thing that they need to prioritize
rather than financial stability uh is it
is perhaps a little reassuring in that
regardless do you think you want to say
about that there are there are abrasive
ft stories to talk about but let's carry
on with that one yeah I just wanted to
to pick up a pipe that David said before
it's absolutely right when he's saying
that the banks are very slow to pass on
that when when the when the raid goes up
they're very slow to pass it on to
servers it's interesting that the
treasury committee have been talking to
the banks about this exact thing and and
listening saying to them give us your
reasoning why you're so quick to put
people's mortgages up but you're not
quick to give Savers the benefits and
and the treasury have said that their
excuses just do not hold water and
they've asked the fan Financial conduct
authority to look into it so maybe we'll
there'll be a you know we'll see a
result from that because it is shocking
Savers lose out all ends and size and so
maybe the financial conduct Authority
will actually deal with this hopefully
they will yeah it's an age-old criticism
isn't it of the banks um the Ft it
doesn't change their behavior though
despite the ideal criticism that's true
true
um Carol the ft is not leading on that
bank of England story though it's
instead leading on uh what was really a
a kicking for the chief executive of uh
Tick Tock over in the United States a
bipartisan kicking at that
yeah yeah Republicans on Democrats going
from you know to some now you know it
was it was interesting seeing sitting
there he looks about 12 actually uh but
I mean that's not the point they're
deciding whether or not they should ban
uh tiktok in the US they nearly did ban
it in 2020.
um and they were in a whisker with that
it wasn't about the same time that India
abandoned that was about 2022.
um uh and interesting that lots of
countries around the world have in
Afghanistan they banned it because they
said it had it had a terrible effect on
young Afghan boys and leading them as
straight
um but it is a dangerous thing this you
know because it's not a apparently the
security risk is huge in there and and
this this guy uh this soy um the cheeked
I can't pronounce his name anyway I'm
sure you can Sam he was asked today
whether
um the Chinese government had Direct
access to the information to the data
and he and he he you know obfuscated he
messed around he said no eventually but
I don't think anyone was buying it
um so it is a huge danger where they can
just you know Harvest information they
can actually it can actually home in on
messages that you're writing to someone
at the time that's how dangerous it is
if you have the app but you know apart
from the security thing which is huge
um and and I think in this country the
band the band or government use of it
and in America they're about to do that
or already have um but but it's also
very dangerous for young people we've
seen you know there was one guy stood up
in the Senate there and said you're
literally killing people your app is
literally killing people and and
something that we saw some of the
because Tick Tock sex challenges for
young people and people might remember
the fun one back in 2016 where there was
the ice bucket challenge so that was fun
people are getting killed waterproof
speak for yourself
to me so it was bad and but you know
that's nothing compared to what's
happening now they're actually they're
they're setting fires of people that was
suicides being filmed on there so it is
really really dangerous and there's also
evidence now that it affects
um young people's brains that it may it
gives them a a shorter attention span
that they um what else there's another
thing as well yeah and it's better
they're saying it's bad for the mental
health that's that's obvious but you
know all apps track us but the way Tick
Tock does it it's it's actually
dystopian it's terrifying it would be
good if everyone just banned this and
where do you think this is going to end
up David because it's also at a time
when U.S Chinese relations have been
pretty Rocky
yes I think there's Carl's done quite a
nice job of delineating the two issues
there on the security issue I think the
problem is that that you ass just don't
trust any Chinese company to be free of
interference from the Chinese government
and if that is the conclusions they're
drawing that has much broader
implications from Tech talk and we've
seen some of that already if you believe
that regardless of what tech talk tell
you in public when they come to to
Washington whatever wherever they put
their servers or whatever security they
put in place that they don't trust the
Chinese government not to be able to
lean on them then I think that has wide
implications for any Chinese company
operating in the rest of the world and
we've seen that obviously the parts that
be the security services in the UK
believe that to be the case as well
because not only in Westminster in the
UK Parliament has happened that's
filtered through to the Scottish
Parliament today where the Scottish
government denies the tech Talk would be
taken off all uh work phones of civil
servants and politicians in Scotland as
well so clearly there is a complete
breakdown in trust there and that and
that is a problem and it speaks to that
deteriorating relationship between China
China and the West so there's that
concern but I think the other wider
issue is as Carol says about tech talk
as a social media platform and the
Damage it does socially regardless of
where it's coming from or how it's being
controlled and and I think that speaks
to a wider issue which we've comes up
quite frequently on this program about
the fact that social media is still a
way a wasteland that is being not
regulated properly and nobody seems to
be able to get a grip of that and deal
with it and I don't really think this is
just scary stories about some of the
problems with eating disorders with
self-harm with with suicide